hello my friends have you been are you
okay
um feels tired already it's just in the
morning come on
I'm Eric I came all the way from Brazil
and today I'm gonna share with you some
crazy experience I was doing at home and
let me tell you there is no such a
content on chat TPT on Google so you can
relate that I spent a long time doing
this so it was pretty pretty interesting
and I hope you like it
so first of all I would like you to get
to know that all this content is already
on the internet so the last slide I'm
gonna put all the links and you can
experiment at home I know that's it's
one hour talk right so it's a bunch of
content to ABS to observe it it's hard
so trying at home I did like a special
tutorial for you and of course take as
many pictures as you can and publish on
internet publish mention me mention the
event because this helps a lot with the
work we've been doing all right very
nice I'm so happy to be here
well everything started when I fixed a
bug in the node.js score so I was
working giving some classes and I found
out that child process had some problem
using echo my scripture modules uh I
know that's a bunch of keywords but just
just to give some some questions
so there because of this book I was
nominated to become part of the node.js
corps part of the team there and I felt
so glad but at the same time I felt like
oh my God I'm imposter I don't know
anything or or I'm not sure how this is
working so I was starting making a lot
of questions for myself and I was like
do I really know what node.js is do I
really know how it's working behind the
scenes and I noticed no I didn't know
much I think this is every day on our
daily life right we are learning and we
get to know that we don't know anything
or we we have a bunch of new things to
learn
so on my YouTube channel I've been doing
a lot of other crazy experiments like
this fixing my own questions so I've
done one implementing the web socket
protocol this was really crazy like
handling binary data and also creating a
code coverage too so everything that I'm
questioning software programming I'm
trying to do from scratch and try
teaching how was the process so it's
been really fun okay recreating node.js
the first thing I was let's try finding
on the internet somebody well node.js is
being there since 2009 so it must be
some other crazy experiments some ideas
on the internet
well it turns out I haven't found
anything no one was using the same
components you could find like some old
GitHub repo but they haven't shown me uh
the right answers so I was like yeah
this is gonna take me a while
well going to the website on node.js you
can understand a bit of the how the
execution module how asynchronous in a
lot of the beauty keyword works but
still I needed more answers I couldn't
find like oh this is the Libya that they
talk is this executed by V8 why there
are so many JavaScript JavaScript
sometimes appearing right now is it
node.js obsolete or why so I started
making a bunch of these questions and
then this talk the craziest things I I
ever done in my life I put house on a
tutorial on YouTube so this talk I got
some right some highlights for you but I
strongly recommend you going there do
this step by step recreating your own
node.js because you can find performance
issues on your current applications you
can understand how node.js is working
behind the scenes and you can fix
libraries that is not following what
node.js sisters
well I just want a disclaimer here okay
are there any C plus plus developer
oh nice so I think we are we are home
right
first of all I'm not a C plus plus
developer so all the demos I'm gonna
show you you're probably gonna see some
bad practices but I try to show the
easiest way so JavaScript developers can
understand okay I know like we're gonna
see very specific syntax but don't pay
too much attention on the C plus plus
let's pay attention what it's doing and
what's the goal behind it
and also everything here is part of my
own research okay I was in Berlin right
on all the Creator was there and I was
shaking because I was looking at his
Ripple his tweets and a lot of stuff
that he was doing the best and I was
just making assumptions right I was
coding planning my ideas but I'm not
sure he haven't never talked to me about
this right so it was pretty interesting
so if I say something wrong here or
something that you find confusing let's
talk after the conference or after the
talk that's gonna help a lot and just a
heads out I I started to give more value
to those guys to those girls who's
working on JavaScript runtimes it's
crazy how they are abstracting the whole
complexity so us we can use JavaScript
which is a very accessible language to
create powerful applications you're
gonna sing practice sometimes no one's
talking about it and it's crazy the
power we have behind the scenes to make
everything work
okay we are here to talk about node.js
everyone's seeing this webpage before
oh nice this was the first node.js
version and you can notice there is no
console.log there's a puts which is from
Ruby right so the first design was just
an experiment a proof of concept that
got viral and really uh turned into a
thing
well I I really want to understand the
context behind the some technology I
want to understand how was the world so
let's think a bit how was the world for
web apis into any online
well I would say was it like
prehistoric like only bad tools there or
why it's hard to think right we had a
bunch of languages back then we had Java
working with JSP servlets uh P2P working
with a lot of Frameworks we had c-sharp
with asp.net it's where I started
working with python with Django and
flask you could see a bunch of
Technologies right so it's hard to to
think why node.js became so popular in a
world that all this those Technologies
were really stable right it's it's
pretty uh interesting to see
well
I started asking myself and asking chat
TPT or about why is this so popular and
I find out back then there were a huge
problem that they are trying to put more
concurrent reusers without having to
scale more servers so all this this uh
languages they have a similar execution
module I'm gonna tell a bit more in a
few slides but it's pretty interesting
it's everyone was following the same
idea and in node.js Everything Has
Changed
I don't know about you but when I start
programming for me it was completely
overwhelming I had to learn
C sharp for the server I had to learn
asp.net for the server to create a web
apis seql to handle databases I had to
learn JavaScript to make some
integration CSS HTML my God was crazy I
thought I would never be a good
programmer I would never learn this
thing so with JavaScript we have one
language that can work in both back and
from the inside and this was a game
changer for everyone so now you can make
people work faster but it's not just it
node.js has a very clever execution
model the way it has changed everything
so let's think about how was the
execution model the popular execution
module back then there we had like data
centers okay and we had requests so when
a request goes to the website usually
those languages are putting threads with
some resource groups there for each
individual client okay each individual
request they have a small piece of
memory CPU and processing power well
if you wanted to put more and more
concurrent users you're gonna be limited
on what your application or what your
servers has on these resources so what
happened you are putting a lot of
customers at the same time you don't
have memory you have to scale up faster
and then you're gonna see a lot of
problems this is mainly cost because the
blocking IO which is uh two tasks there
that are trying to access a file access
a databases they are uh basically
pausing so other processes can finish
first in a big picture in Threads are
heavy in those scenarios so imagine for
each customer I have a bunch of threads
a bunch of resources so it's pretty
expensive for the web services which it
was hard to handle concurrent users and
usually we had like huge servers to
handle all of this and it's not that it
when you're working with trads threads
has to be careful managed so you can
avoid the Deadlocks right so this is
when two applications are are uh two
processes are trying to change the same
value in memory the same reference in
memory using the server just breaks and
say oh I don't know who who will go
first so we have to implement like
semaphores in a lot of crazy Concepts
with node.js none of this were a problem
node.js came with another completely
different approach so you can handle a
multiple and concurrent application
users you can use real-time applications
by by changing the hallway so in node.js
the execution model is a bit different
it handles a bunch of users by using a
very interesting execution module so
everything inside node.js is
asynchronous which means that my
application can schedule tasks can
schedule background programs and then
when these programs are ready to respond
they call them back and the application
is ready so you have a loop there
instead of having a lot of uh
resources and threads for each
individual user node.js just
pre-allocated on the startup so we have
everything on the startup and then we
can start reusing for each concurrent
user so now we can have all those users
when I'm receiving those requests I'm
putting on a queue there I'm scheduling
those requests and then I can receive a
bunch of users I can just enqueue them
on my processing time but then we have
something that is very non-called there
as a loop right as event Loop so when
this Loop is running it's removing or
responding to the users without having
to pause the process okay so on the main
fret we have all this dispatching of
events and then in background everything
is running seamlessly by the process
so the main thing for node.js it it's
it's not reserving memory for each
individual client it can reuse more
memory so that's why there are a bunch
of people using like Raspberry Pi's like
small small servers to handle a bunch of
concurrent users using OJs
okay so just to highlight node.js is was
amazing back then because it uses a
non-blocking IO so if this means that it
doesn't need to stop them in thread it
doesn't need to block an execution for
uh some task
and it uses the lightweight processes
the event Loop in the end is like a
while true event a while true Loop there
that's just asking for more events
dispatching and just making the link
between your repair system and the user
interface right the request itself
and then it enforces asynchronous
programming so now you can uh schedule
tasks in background you can use more the
power of your machine to uh get all this
so you can handle multiple tasks in
parallel and running a bunch of other
things in uh
asynchronously right and they hope the
whole goal was to create real-time
applications so now concurrent users are
not the problem anymore
and just I think just last myth with
before getting to the code right node.js
has always been working with threads but
I've seen people say no JavaScript
doesn't have threads node.js doesn't
have threads and this was really weird
for me really misleading so I I wanted
to see in practice how this worked
node.js do have the thread since the
beginning so when I was looking at the
v001 form I was like oh my god there are
threads here so everyone else was
telling me wrong right this is why I I
think only believing Theory doesn't make
sense we should pry and understand how
this works behind the scenes
when you go to the node.js website
you're gonna notice the worker pull the
worker pool are usually four threads
that node.js puts on the startup right
so it's scheduling a worker pull so you
can run intensive CPU tasks behind the
scenes so there are a bunch of texts
here don't worry let's just highlight
what is important so node.js uses two
threads queue expensive tasks and those
tasks would be IO intensive like DNS
that is synchronous so node.js has to
have some way to execute them in
parallel or CPU intensive crypto
encryption compression files and much
more okay however since the V10 we have
the worker Frets okay and and then
people are like oh well node.js has
always used threads but it wasn't
available right it wasn't on a public
API now now you can use this API to
create and process uh more things more
CPU intensive tests behind the scenes
okay but usually this is for very
specific very edge cases to uh use on
your JavaScript applications
well and we were talking node.js is much
trading but the event Loop is single
threaded and this is what makes this
special The Event club is single
threaded so it doesn't need to check
variables okay every process is executed
sequentially and just receive the data
back and forth from the operating system
so this is really fast to execute and
this is very crazy
I'm gonna tell about all the keywords
but just so you know the libuv that we
are talking a lot for the event Loop the
the Libya view was made uh for node.js
to work on Windows on Mac in a lot of
operating systems
all right a bunch of Fury right I think
it's time to to getting some code and
see how this works in practice right so
for me now it's time to see the magic
happening right so let's we're creating
node.js what I meant while I speak
recreate node.js I want to use the same
components that node.js is using and I
want to do at least a set timeout
because I want to use the V8 that I I
didn't tell you yet what is this and I
want to use the Libya V to create
process in background and see everything
working this was they go I was trying to
find so I found the internet I could
find some uh examples on running only
individual pieces of those projects were
but known uh
alone
and then I always go to the repo the
node.js and I try to understand how Ryan
though how the Creator was thinking when
he was the first version right with zero
zero one and I would say it's pretty
pretty interesting uh sometimes we have
our heroes and we are like oh my god
there must be the best programmers in
the world they don't commit fails
but you're gonna see on the commit
history it's really interesting first
compile intermediate commit nothing
working he just put three dots there I
have no idea what I meant and then add a
web page very incomplete so you can see
he's very uh Perfection is for
everything right uh trying to implement
extremely load not working
this is interesting for me because when
it's not working I don't usually put on
the repo right but he said it was a
proof of concept he wasn't aware if it
everything's gonna work so he was just
just trying try until it worked
well and you see this code the V1 all
right the first release was just in 2014
the zero zero one was 2009 so you can
see a huge gap there right node.js back
then they have a very uh the community
enjoyance the company that was behind in
OJs they had a fight so node.js had a
fork on this and they start calling this
a web iojs right so it was pretty
interesting because we we had two
exactly the same projects running in a
lot of fights on the community but
hopefully all this this this this this
fight has passed and node.js is working
fine with all the community
okay
all this project I told you using all
the the the components that node.js is
using is already on the GitHub so you
can find all the code and I call this
capybara so capybara is a very known
animal in Brazil so I try to bring some
references and I'm gonna tell you I
spend at least a month doing this for
this project so first I try to to
compile and to execute different
libraries right different uh process so
the first one was the V8 V8 is the
JavaScript interpreter so it's like I'm
using Evo in JavaScript I can send I
string to the this library or to this
component and it's gonna evaluate my
code and return the result okay just it
well but let me tell you a story when I
got there I tried to follow this step by
step following the docs it wasn't
working well I just changed my Mac from
uh
an arm to an emu one it was my God it
was crazy crazy so just you know the
first process is downloading from the
repo so after I download this from the
repo it's gigabytes it's crazy massive
files everywhere
I had to set up the architecture so now
I'm using me one so I had to recompile
everything from my machine to work my
God C plus plus is pretty hard I'm not C
plus plus developer but I suffered a lot
doing this and I had to start compiling
so this is the time you go there you get
your coffee your talk to your wife
because it's long time right and I would
say on this process going back and forth
I spent three weeks because I was
compiling the code I wasn't getting the
right results it always always missing
some files and it was pretty hard but
after you do the right way you wait I at
least one plus hours so you can see
everything working after you compile the
code it's gonna be like eight gigabytes
there the final project and you can run
the test so you can run all the VA tests
that is testing how the language Works
itself and you can copy the binary and
the headers well this time you're gonna
be thinking oh my God there's two too
much information right
uh when you go to your home and you try
to do this tutorial I did everything
more straightforward for you okay so I
set up a cloud environment on the git
pod in there I compiled those libraries
I put in there so you can only think
about the code so when you go there
you're gonna see all the the the
payments is already there so you can
only focus on C plus plus node.js leave
UV and so on uh if you want to try I put
the the link and the the scripts there
but it wasn't a a really easy task to
start working on
okay we are here to talk about
JavaScript node.js and all those fancy
logos right so I'm going to show you now
the relationship between them so if you
forget everything from this talk I want
you to remember just the next steps okay
so V8 is our interpreter Libya V is the
event manager right everything that goes
asynchronous we use libuv and C plus
plus is what we call the bridge is the
link sending data from one side and
calling other side so how this works in
practice V8 as I told you is grammar
right all data types all data structures
that are in the JavaScript side on the
Acme script is there so cost function
classes promises map sets and so on okay
you're gonna notice here that there are
no
console.log there are no uh console that
there's no set time out set interval
immediate
it's weird right so when you get the V8
it's very raw so you can start
implementing your own functions
so we have the Libya V and in this case
the Libya V I'm gonna tell you it's just
a while true asking for events okay it's
going to go there and say oh is there
any asynchronous event painting I'm
gonna dispatch them all and I'm gonna
use there
and then we have where the magic happens
where I think that the the those JS
runtimes authors they help us a lot
because it's here how they make
JavaScript powerful to work on servers
and even on browsers right
so imagine I have a JavaScript file okay
we have the context the global days of
JavaScript and it's there's nothing
there right that it's completely empty
so we had to start implementing flanges
I won't Implement console.log I'm going
to implement print okay so this print
function it doesn't exist in JavaScript
so if I try running this function it's
gonna show me that's undefined so what I
do I go to the C plus plus sign I
Implement a new function there okay and
with this function I'm gonna extend V8
and say whatever you have this call you
call this C plus plus function okay so
this is how all the magic happens behind
the scenes this is how FS Works HTTP
requests in everything that you can use
from negative modules in node.js
oh bless you nice what if I want to
implement set timeout set timeout is a
bit higher right
I have the sad timeout I will make
exactly the same thing for the C plus
plus side but notice that now I'm using
UV timer start with like everything that
goes outside my cone everything that
relies on the environment I'm gonna call
from liby side and now on V8 you can see
all those functions right all those
functions are now mapped there as if it
was JavaScript as it was always there so
this is the magic behind most of the
runtimes right now
well I would tell you that my first
thing was oh my God this is just
extending V8 right so in the end I'm
just adding new functions but how when
or how a dino or other runtimes are so
popular now if they are just trying
doing the same stuff they're trying
doing the same idea
well we're gonna get into it okay now
I'm gonna show you more code now I'm
gonna show you how the process is
working behind and what is cool about
implementing this code
all right first of all
I have my code here okay so it's a
JavaScript code you can see just a print
in a new date
the date object is interesting for me
because date depends or relies on your
environment right but it's the only
thing on JavaScript that can follow this
idea otherwise other runtimes or other
platforms browsers could Implement
themselves
so here I have all that they structure
for my code okay but let's take a look
at this some ideas here I have very C
plus plus code and this C plus plus code
is just getting the arguments and
getting a file name and it's gonna read
this file and we try start executing it
so I'm gonna go there
and see I'm just let's see step by step
right I received the file name okay and
in the file name I'm just reading a file
just sit I'm gonna get all the
JavaScript code and I'm gonna put on a
variable okay
then I'm gonna use this compile this is
why I was telling you JavaScript doesn't
exist JavaScript in the end it's just V8
translating all those strings or all
that grammar to C plus plus instances
for me was like oh this is pretty pretty
mind-blowing
and then just to check it out this what
is inside this read file uh actually we
have uh the script run so the script run
is the Evolve right it's the execution
so before I compile it I have the C plus
plus extensions and C plus plus
functions and then I probably executed
but let's take a look here I have the
weight for events I'm gonna show it
later but just so you know see oh
oops
let's forward a bit just so you know the
fs file that I was telling you the read
file is just a c plus function let me
get here
so I'm using the most primitive way of
reading files in C plus but this is very
a C plus plus side but for me was in the
end it doesn't matter what is the
platform it just matter what is uh the
apis you're calling to interact with
your operating system it could have been
rust it could have been any other
programming language that is interacting
with C plus plus and here you can see
that I'm not using Libya V right I'm
using the C plus plus native abstraction
here but I'm using this because on the
startup I just want to get all the
content from the file and execute it I
don't need to be asynchronous this time
because the startup is the most
important thing right now
nice
okay so now I have to get all those
binaries right I have to put on the same
directory and then I had to make a way
to link all them together so when I'm
using C plus plus I have to tell where
is the binary okay the binary is that
monolith dot a that usually is like a
hundred megabytes just this binary and
then I have to put all the C plus plus
includes which is the references well on
how I'm gonna call a functions from that
binary
and then I have to put all my directory
and the same for Libya V so environment
is really really painful this is why I
think uh having this on gift pod is
going to help you a lot to go forward
okay
I'm not a c plus developer right I'm
JavaScript developer and I use those
mode a lot so I was like what not using
node mod to uh evaluate my C plus
classes so I'm using a node mode here to
execute the make file and then run the
binary I don't know much about C plus
plus other tooling so I try using what I
really knew so it was really really
interesting
and here if I try running I run the make
file okay and then it's gonna generate a
binary for me and with this binary I can
execute it as node.js is executing right
node.js is just a binary it's just a C
plus plus file that's receiving string a
file in evaluating this data for me it
was really miss emissify right
okay
I was telling you that console.log
doesn't exist right so what happens if
you try calling console.log let's check
this out this was really really
interesting for me if I go there I print
console.log and see nothing happens not
even an error right I should see like
log is undefined function right but no I
haven't seen any output here however if
I use my print function and put the
console log there
I see the console I see it's an object
I was like wait wait wait wait wait
console.log is there but it's just not
working right if I get the keys from
this object
I'm gonna see all the functions there
I was like why do you have all the
functions but I cannot execute them so
this is just a standard I would say V8
is doing this just to make you uh make
your your program uh happen better
one thing that I'm keep telling you but
for me was the mind-blowing stuff is set
timeout set interval in consoler not
JavaScript this means that if you
execute your JavaScript code on the
browser the browser is responsible to
implement the console log or the set
timeout implementation this is why
Firefox Google and all those browsers I
are fighting now because one can be
faster than another implementing their
own way to execute those factors so this
is pretty nice if we go back to our code
what happens if we go there and type the
set timeout not Define it right very
different than the console example okay
what about the interval
same problem right not Define it well
actually it's not just messy okay there
are working groups that tell us how node
how console and how timers should be
implemented in JavaScript runtimes it's
not just messy okay but they are not
there by default and it's pretty pretty
interesting for me
okay we did the print the print was just
a print F on the C plus plus side
nothing fun but now I want to link all
of the libraries all the dependencies so
you can try at home and try even
implementing OJs if you want but see
here I have the print function and the
first time I saw this code it was like
oh no man bring F when I was in the
university the printf was like the first
French I saw in my life and it's been
using things like nowadays on the
node.js side and it's pretty pretty
interesting
it's a bunch of information isn't it
so here I have this C plus plus I'm
gonna try doing the same thing I showed
you on the diagram so I have the C plus
plus function the print function that's
going to be called from JavaScript I
have to extend this C plus plus side
right I have to extend the V8 object and
say whenever someone called print show
this function
and after it
and after it we can execute and just so
you know the print function is here just
to to print out the informations but I'm
gonna show you that JavaScript is much
more uh V8 there are a lot of things
there right just doing only the print
function I didn't do any other objects
but you see new date is there two ISO
string is there also uh string templates
are there as well and even complex
instruction complex objects such as map
and spread operator and surprisingly
promises are not async functions
promises are just abstractions so you
can use callbacks behind the scenes this
was like oh my God so yeah promises they
are not making anything a scene for you
just helping you out to work with your
photos nice we have implemented the
print now let's implement the set
timeout in set interval right
so yeah it's time for me it was one of
the most interesting things to do
because when I have to execute remember
node.js can handle multiple concurrent
users right a lot of of users executing
the application but when I have this set
timeout I have to schedule a function
that's going to be executed in the
future so that piece of object those
parameters should be in memory when I
have to access there so I was like oh my
God how node.js is doing this for so
many users concurrently
well let's go there and let's find out
so I have my timeout function again it's
C plus plus but just don't get the
concept I'm getting both parameters here
they sleep how long the timeout's gonna
happen and the interval so if it's an
interval it's the same function I just
changed uh the parameter there another
thing I'm gonna call and see if the user
pass a callback so I can call it in the
future
and now it's this part here I spent I
would say two weeks I almost gave up
doing that because I didn't know how to
store those variables how to start those
objects so I had I started making calls
to people from Google and they were like
I have no idea what you're doing but
some guys has helped me to really finish
it so this is a struct I'm using some uh
node.js or some V8 uh instructions there
but I'm just starting those objects
starting those uh parameters to be
executed in the future and now I use the
libuv methods when I saw people on the
posts on articles I thought it was way
higher right but it's just C plus plus
instructions it's just functions as we
do in JavaScript
so when this function executed I have
the Callback there so the Callback would
say well now it's time to execute it
execute the Callback that the user thing
the user just passed to you and this is
so magic that we can invoke the
JavaScript code
see JavaScript doesn't exist we are
invoking the V8 call right the V8
function which is an instance this is
why I'm telling you that JavaScript is
just it's like an intermediate language
for us right
and then see if we go to the JavaScript
site now
actually we have to put all the event
Loop right the while true there to wait
for a new event so the set timeout reach
the time the leave UV it's gonna
schedule and release all the process for
this function
and then we just call it right after
confining and executing our code okay
nice don't forget to put on our uh
context as we've done to the print and
now it's going to be available on the
JavaScript side and see now look how
amazing is it on the JavaScript side now
I have the timeout right so I have all
the abstraction and remember my time out
I I just to make the interval I just
have to switch the parameters and they
receive callbacks
but as I was telling you promises they
are just abstractions right promises are
just a way to help us to wait for
results however when I'm doing this I
can use async in await and if I run this
code it magically happens magically
works and wait for the seconds and wait
for everything working
I wouldn't say I cannot explain how it
was for me to reach this result I was
like calling everyone's like oh my God
it finally worked because it was pretty
pretty hard and node.js is a C plus plus
is a new word for me so I was struggling
a lot
well
node.js uh uh in the first version when
I was looking I saw that Ryan doll did a
very similar code right you can see he
was using timer and he was exposing
those functions from there so when you
go to the node.js serves we're gonna see
a bunch of C plus plus code in a bunch
of JavaScript code right so what they
are trying to do they are trying to
expose those apis so you can make your
own abstractions from the JavaScript
side so you you cannot you don't need to
handle concurrency or or handle those
weird syntax from C plus plus
so remember JavaScript it's only about
my script specs okay so if you if you're
not working if you can see that those
functions not working it's probably not
in the JavaScript in the xmascript spec
so you can have implemented by yourself
okay
well the next chapter now is try
understanding why we have so many
JavaScript from times now
I saw Ben and Ben is is very interesting
but Dino I like more because they fight
right Dino is just the node.js uh
backwards and I think my whole
motivation was is it that easy to create
a JavaScript from time uh are they
making money why why they are creating a
lot of JS runtimes and how is this good
or bad for our community right let's
talk about Dino
has a very good approach using
typescript using instead of using V
instead of using libov it's using Tokyo
which is in rest so ever the whole
project is rust
and architecture is very similar if you
take a look at the code you're gonna see
there that they have a execute script
which is the function that translates
the JavaScript code now to rest right
exactly the same thing we were doing in
the C plus plus side if we look at the
execution exactly the same way they are
compiling and they are executing and get
those Magics using the V8 uh apis so
it's just a different programming
language but doing exactly the same
workflow well and if you go there you
can see that demo is injecting a lot of
functions on the global stage right on
the they go about this as I was doing on
the diagram remember so exactly the same
idea behind the scenes what about Dino
oh what about burn B what about burn
it has using Zig I don't know him it for
me it was crazy Zig there are just few
content on internet and they are using a
JavaScript core for the JavaScript firm
time JavaScript core there are almost
non-documentation so probably this guy
has some information that we don't know
because the dogs are almost no so I
can't find anything
however
when going to this website you're gonna
see a bunch of imports so we can see
JavaScript core there you can see a
bunch in this case is C plus plus right
so he's trying to do some bindings uh to
use on zinc but it's exactly the same
idea I wouldn't I wouldn't go further on
this code because Zig is very confusing
for me so I I didn't go much but it's
exactly the same idea extending one
function or extending ideas from the
existing uh Js runtimes
now we we are we start making questions
right well they are all extending uh
JavaScript from times what makes one
faster or better than another right so
why are they fighting now or why they
are competing this Market if they are
trying to do the same exact thing
well let's see this code this code is
for the fs the node.js library to
accessing files and all the file system
apis
node.js has a bunch of apis they know
the same thing and but the same thing
but one one makes one better than others
it's how they handle this responses from
the operating system so the operating
system you are calling for a file the
the file would be big right but you are
handling it on demand you are responding
to the JavaScript site on demand so this
is how one could be faster than another
so let's say that's Zig for doing Loops
or handling buffers which is a crazy
idea behind these things it's using a
better approach
uh but I would say nothing of this is
important for us if we don't have a good
developer experience right so developer
experience for me it's where Dino was
pretty good right it just started with
testing uh and it just started very
performatic it was starting with
typescript so a lot of people loved it
but for me it's crazy just seeing how
node.js has improved because of them
node.js has now a working group for
performance they are if you go like from
the version 16 to 20 you're gonna see a
complete different platform so it's
getting faster every day and remember I
said to you right about the competition
let's see this Jared summer which is the
balance Creator he's joined node.js so
he's there trying to collaborate try to
understand getting ideas from Burn and
back and forth calling rig calling rig
was one of the maintainers or I think
he's actually his maintainer of Libya V
it was one of the first developers of
node.js he has worked at Dino and they
are all contributing together and you
see the test Runner uh was a big thing
in the the dino side and we brought to
the node.js and I I personally I've been
working a lot on this
a lot of information isn't it oh I see
just like 404 faces from here but it's
really nice it's be nice and I think
you're gonna have time to digest later
well something nice about uh those
collaborations right are they working
groups that I have been appearing I
think in the future we won't have to
change or we won't have to choose
whether it's node.js burn cloudflare
workers or whatever runtime we cannot
say oh AWS I want to run my JavaScript
site here the apis are the same so the
platform could choose it so this working
group is meant for them to collaborate
and to talk to each other about the same
all right so
as I told you
this tutorial will help you a lot I
think you're gonna observe more when you
are taifi I know it's it's hard
sometimes to listen to this kind of
stuff but I enjoy it so much because now
I can understand better and I came
actually troubleshoot my applications
better I can say um probably I have a
memory leak because the event is taking
too long or probably I have this
JavaScript code which is a while loop
handling a million items in memory
probably it's there because it's not
asynchronous so when you start paying
attention on how the behind the scenes
work this helps us a lot to improve our
current applications
nice
so all the content I'm talking to you is
already on my website all the talks I've
been doing all the JavaScript crazy
ideas I've been doing is already there
and for this specific talk I did an
ebook so on this ebook you can go there
and you could do they step by step from
the book but it's not just the
step-by-step as the video was showing
you you can go there and Implement your
own FS module so it's pretty pretty
interesting
all right so we have uh a few new
minutes right now I'm gonna open four
questions I know that's very crazy
subject but if you have questions you
can raise your hand
so we can we can do oh
any questions
it's crazy isn't it like our just our
mind is freezing out right now Okay so
before I finish this talk right I
usually we have a tradition so I'm gonna
put the last slide here so you can take
a picture and get all those references
all these links all these slides also
but before we finish we usually do a
crazy stuff right just to make people at
house at home Envy let's make a selfie
oh let's oh stretch a bit out right and
get ready for the next talk
so
I'm gonna count three and we're gonna do
whoa okay
I'm counting anyway
one two three
very nice thank you so much for having
me
[Applause]